einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu unserem live stream
ihr habt es gerade schon eingeblendet
gesehen 23 1648 das ist sozusagen die
zahl des tages ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen in den letzten 24 stunden
und damit stellt sich die frage ist das
was wir im moment gegen die korona
pandemie tun ist das ausreichend ist die
zweite welle noch zu brechen ihr könnt
gerne darüber mit diskutieren und fragen
stellen wir immer über youtube facebook
oder auch über die eingeblendete zdf
adresse
unser gesprächspartner heute abend ist
zum wiederholten male professor
brockmann von der humboldt universität
zu berlin und darüber hinaus auch tätig
am robert-koch-institut er ist physiker
forscht zu komplexen systemen zum
beispiel auch zu computergestützter
epidemiologie und in diesem zusammenhang
beschäftigt er sich auch mit dem corona
virus einen schönen guten abend herr
brockmann schön dass sie wieder bei uns
sind nun abend herr brockmann knapp
24.000 neuinfektionen innerhalb der
letzten 24 stunden mit welcher
gefühlsregungen nehmen sie diese zahl
zur kenntnis ja also etwas sich immer
als erstes machen wenn eine zahl kommt
für einen neuen tag dann vergleiche ich
die mit der mit der zahl eine woche
vorher weil wir ja immer in der woche
diese schwankungen haben die mit dem
meldesystem was zu tun haben das heißt
ich vergleiche die mit letztem freitag
und dem freitag davor und da ist jetzt
erst einmal festzustellen dass das in
der größenordnung in etwa gleich liegt
also von der woche hatten wir auch
20.000 fälle und vor zwei wochen etwa
auch so hat sich das jetzt eingependelt
das heißt im vergleich zu den wochen
vorher sind wir auf einem konstanten
niveau aber auch sehr hohen konstanten
niveau
genau das werden wir gleich noch
vertiefen herr brockmann wir sprechen
gleich weiter wollen uns vorher aber
noch mal genau die entwicklung auch der
letzten drei wochen anschauen seitdem es
irgendwie die verschafften corona
maßnahmen gibt mehr dazu von meiner
kollegin nina niebergall die zahl der
korona neuinfektion hat einen neuen
rekordstand
das robert koch institut meldet 23 1648
neue fälle innerhalb eines tages um
sieben tage schnitt hatten sich ende
oktober noch 13 1090 menschen angesteckt
also vor der einführung der aktuellen
corona maßnahmen die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist danach bis zum 8
november angestiegen seitdem steigen
jetzt hier auf diesem niveau gestern lag
sie bei 18.000 380 18 1380 also herr
professor brockmann die zahlen scheinen
sich auf einem relativ hohen niveau sie
sagten es selber gerade schon
einzupendeln für wie stabil halten sie
dieses plateau und ist denn dieses
niveau was wir da sehen auch auf dauer
so akzeptabel
also das ist sehr schwer gerade zu sagen
weil es halt ein plateau ist das heißt
wir sind seit einigen wochen also auch
schon vor dem ersten hälfte aus diesem
exponentiellen wachstum aus dieser
extrem starken beschleunigungen
rausgekommen und dann ist dieses
wachstum immer stärker gesunken so dass
es jetzt ein plateau erreicht hatten das
ist halt wie beim bergsteigen man hat
sozusagen einen hügel erklommen und dann
bildet sich halt ein plateau und dann
ist es wenn man noch nicht ganz so genau
in die zukunft gucken kann sehr schwer
zu sagen ob es danach unter geht oder ob
es danach noch ein anstieg gibt die
hoffnung ist natürlich dass es jetzt
wieder auch nach unten geht
wir gucken uns gleich auch noch mal die
kurve des plateaus beziehungsweise
überhaupt die kur wird den ansteckungen
genauer an mit hilfe einer grafik aber
vielleicht vorher nochmal die frage es
gab ja bei vielen durchaus die hoffnung
auch muss man sagen durch die politik
zumindest nicht im keim erstickt das ist
nach dem november im prinzip ein ende
hätte mit den corona maßnahmen das ist
doch wieder zu lockerungen kommen könnte
jetzt ist nächste woche am mittwoch ein
neues bund länder treffen da wird noch
mal beratschlagt und auch wahrscheinlich
entschieden
das sieht doch alles in allem ein
bisschen eng aus mit einer unbeschwerten
sommer mal advents und weihnachtszeit
oder wie ist ihre einschätzung
ja also es ist ja irgendwie klar gewesen
dass wenn man maßnahmen ergreift auch
wenn die leute selbstständig ihr
verhalten wieder ändern weil die angst
wieder
größer geworden ist und das ist hat sich
halt quasi durch durchgesetzt auch in
der erkenntnis dass wir mitten in der
zweiten welle waren als das exponentiell
wieder hoch ging das dann dauert bis
diese effekte zu wirken wir sind ja auch
immer in so einem verzug
das heißt die zahlen die wir jetzt sehen
sind ja schon vor zwei wochen passiert
das muss man auch immer sehen aber es
ist in der tat so dass wir jetzt in der
dritten woche sind im lock down und die
modelle die ich kenne die diese
verschiedenen szenarien durchgespielt
haben haben verglichen was passiert wenn
man 40 prozent der kontakte reduziert 50
oder 70 prozent
und wenn man das unterscheidet dann
sieht man halt je weniger kontakte
reduziert werden gibt es auch fälle wo
dann die fälle wieder runtergehen das
dann aber auch sehr lange dauert bis sie
dann wieder ein akzeptables niveau
erreicht haben und die intensiver die
lockdown maßnahmen sind desto schneller
passiert das in diese richtung fragt
auch nick touch bei uns über youtube
warum hat sich die lage bei rund 20.000
neuinfektionen pro tag stabilisiert hat
das was mit dem zweiten locker und zu
tun
das ist eine super frage also es gibt
zwei einflüsse die man sehen kann das
problem ist nur dass wir nicht so genau
unterscheiden können jedenfalls nicht in
den modellen welcher einfluss da
überwogen hat also wir haben gesehen
dass eine abweichung von dem
exponentiellen wachstums schon vor dem
lockdown messbar war das heißt die
menschen haben schon reagiert weil sie
halt gesehen haben wir sind hier wieder
in einer sehr ernsten situation
und da kam schon der erste die ersten
leichten abweichungen und dann kamen ab
dem ersten elf die maßnahmen und auch
die werden dann später erst wirksam das
heißt wir haben schon sachen vor dem
ersten elf gesehen die er dann auch
wieder ein bis zwei wochen vorher
eigentlich passiert sind
so ist es ein gemisch von von dingen
dass menschen halt freiwillig erkennen
hier müssen sie sich wieder anders
verhalten und die wirkung der maßnahmen
das wirkt zusammen es lässt sich sehr
schwer auseinander rechnen was da
überwiegt herr professor bob an ich
würde gerne noch ihre meinung ab holen
so ein paar grafiken die wir auch
vorbereitet haben
ich liebe user oder ihr euch besser
gesagt auch anschauen könnt zum beispiel
auf zdf heute.de oder auch mit der zdf
heute ab da gibt es zum einen eben um
die schon besprochen die zahl der
neuinfektionen in deutschland das kann
man hier auch noch mal ganz kurz ganz
gut erkennen also wir hatten hier unten
ja so beginn des jahres bzw
zu beginn der pandemie im märz april
eine zahl von knapp 6.000 und dann
schauen wir noch mal hoch auf der
rechten seite 19 öfter der aktuelle
stand 18 1380 das ist also sozusagen da
jetzt schon wieder etwas runter
gerechnet da sind ja auch immer
durchschnittswerte die da gebildet
werden also man sieht schon dass sich
dieses plateau leicht abflacht dazu
hatten wir gerade schon gesprochen das
ist ganz interessant sich hier auch auf
dieser seite mal ein bisschen
umzuschauen
die todesfälle sind auch dargestellt das
ist ja auch immer ein ja doch ein klein
ein faktor und eine kategorie auf die
man natürlich auch schaut
und sie können gerne auch dazu noch mal
was sagen dann haben wir hier auch
nochmal eine grafik in der man auch noch
mal sieht dass diese fälle jetzt
zumindest was den peak angeht die spitze
angeht etwas unter dem liegen was wir zu
beginn des jahres schon gesehen haben
207 aber natürlich auch mit einer
steigenden tendenz professor brockmann
wie wirken diese zahlen auf sie hier
haben wir zum beispiel auch noch mal die
intensivbehandlung was die zahl der
betten angeht da übrigens der wert
relativ hoch also diese ganzen zahlen
was zum beispiel intensivbetten
behandlung angeht was zum beispiel
todeszahlen angeht mit welchen emotionen
welche emotionen nehmen sie das wahr bzw
wie schauen sie auf diese zahlen
ja also erstmal ist es ganz wichtig dass
man sich verschiedene kurven anschaut
also verschiedene daten
wir haben die meldezahlen wir haben auch
die anzahl der intensivbetten die dann
belegt sind und auch die todesfälle und
die haben natürlich das spielen in
verschiedenen kurven auch noch
verschiedene faktoren eine rolle
aber wenn man natürlich sieht dass all
diese kurven in etwa den gleichen
anstieg haben oder dann auch in ein
exponentielles wachstum oder auch eine
sättigung gehen dann sprechen all diese
kurven in etwa die gleiche sprache
erinnern uns als es um den ersten
anstieg der
der zweiten welle ging da wurde auch
argumentiert ja es wird auch mehr
getestet könnte das nicht daran liegen
und dann muss man sich die test positiv
rate anschauen wie viele leute denn
eigentlich mit einem positiven test nach
hause gehen
auch das ist eine andere kurve die sie
auch übrigens da auf der seite haben
die muss man sich alle im strauß
angucken quasi also alle zusammen um
dann besser verstehen zu können was
jetzt gerade passiert und ob zum
beispiel dieser diese spitze die wir
jetzt erreicht haben ob das tatsächlich
ein längerfristiges plateau ist oder ob
das tatsächlich eine kurven bewegung ist
die auch sozusagen mit schwung wieder
nach unten geht
das kann beides passieren aber man muss
das sich alles immer zusammenhang kommen
simon bergmann auf facebook fragt warum
wird aktuell so wenig getestet und zum
einen ist das so und zum anderen warum
das ist das ist relativ
das hat auch mit test kapazitäten hängt
das zusammen und auch mit test
strategien also wie man testet das sind
so epidemiologische fragen die ich als
modellieren nicht wirklich sinnhaft
beantworten kann weshalb welche
strategie gewählt wird eine ein sich ein
faktor sicherlich ist kapazität von
tests und den sinnvollen einsatz der
test die da sind
verstehe ich würde gerne mit ihnen noch
auf ein weiteres thema schauen weil das
momentan eben auch ja doch schwer
diskutiert wird in den medien da geht es
zum einen um den unterricht um die
schulen und natürlich auch da um den
umgang mit dem virus und vor allem auch
um die frage was wird hier von
bundesland zu bundesland auch
unterschiedlich gehandhabt unbestreitbar
ist allerdings dass das nach wie vor
eben ein bereich ist in dem relativ
viele menschen auf relativ engem raum
zusammenkommen wir schauen gerade auch
da noch mal auf den aktuellen stand der
problematik
die schulen sollen offen bleiben in
dieser zweiten welle so lange wie
möglich
damit das klappt hat das
robert-koch-institut ziemlich klare
empfehlungen ausgegeben ab der
kritischen grenze von 50 neuinfektionen
pro 100000 einwohner innen soll im
klassenraum masken pflicht gelten die
klassen halbiert werden
[Musik]
doch corona maßnahmen für schulen das
ist ländersache
in bayern etwa gilt bei einem corona
fall muss die ganze klasse für zehn tage
in quarantäne
andere bundesländer schicken teilweise
nur die sitznachbar ihnen nach hause
die konkrete entscheidung treffen die
gesundheitsämter vor ort abhängig vom
hygiene konzept der einzelnen schulen
und wenn es nach der kanzlerin geht soll
bundesweit sowieso mehr einheitlichkeit
her
sie will klassen dauerhaft teilen die
eine hälfte im präsenzunterricht die
andere im distanz unterricht zu hause
ob dieser plan umgesetzt wird das könnte
sich kommende woche entscheiden beim
nächsten bund länder treffen wenn die
schulen ganz oben auf der agenda stehen
dürften
wie bewerten sie denn als mann der
zahlen sozusagen die rolle der schulen
in der pandemie welchen beitrag zur
verbreitung des virus sehen sie da
wollen wir das genau wüssten dann
müssten wir ja auch genau was die
richtige entscheidung hier wäre also
natürlich ist es so dass auch an schulen
infektionsgeschehen stattfindet herrscht
aber uneinigkeit darüber inwiefern das
wichtig ist oder ein sehr starker faktor
in dem gesamtbudget ist und wir müssen
ja immer auch bedenken dass letztendlich
eine frau merkel hat gesagt jeder
kontakt der nicht stattfindet es ein
guter kontakt und das ist richtig das
heißt im idealfall würden wir auf alle
kontakte zu jeder zeit verzichten und
dann wäre das virus demnächst weg aber
das kommt natürlich mit einem preis und
ein hoher preis ist die schulen zu
schließen
das versteht natürlich jeder auch sofort
und deshalb muss man immer genau abwägen
welchen preis zahlt man dafür dass man
gegeben
falls länger wartet bis die welle wieder
runtergeht und diese entscheidung zum
beispiel die empfehlung dass man in
schulen dass die schülerinnen und
schüler masken tragen ist ja ein
vergleichsweise niedriges opfer was man
bringen kann und dennoch unterrichten
kann also präsenzunterricht haben kann
weil wir ja auch immer mehr evidenz
haben dass diese masken wirklich ein
starkes wirksames mittel sind um
kontakte in ihrer wirksamkeit zu
reduzieren also wenn ich da kurz ein
haken darf also die masken pflicht an
allen schulen für auch alle schüler also
eben auch in den grundschulen zb das ist
etwas was sie befürworten würden höre
ich da jetzt raus
ja genau das wie alle modellierer die
ich kenne die dazu was sagen können was
sozusagen aus den modellen abgeleitet
werden kann befürworten dieses vorgehen
weil wir ja auch immer dann sozusagen
prüfen müssen das ist sozusagen das
opfer das gebracht wird in diesem
zusammenhang und deshalb ist die
empfehlung sagte er auch dass ab einer
gewissen schwelle von incidents das dann
auch passiert damit gewährleistet wird
dass die schulen nicht zu so einer art
drehkreuz werden es kommt ja auch nicht
nur an wie hoch die inzidenz an
bestimmten orten ist sondern wer welche
menschen an diesen zusammentreffen
das sind können ja dann auch zum
beispiel in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
der treffen menschen zusammen die sich
nicht kennen und selbst wenn da das
infektionsgeschehen gering ist wird es
dann sozusagen von einem pflaster in den
nächsten getragen das ist auch ganz
wichtig zu verschwinden gerne noch ganz
kurz beim thema schule bleiben weil das
jetzt auch gerade im beitrag aufgeworfen
wurde und weil darüber auch viel
diskutiert wird wie sehen sie das mit
dem geteilten klassen sinnvoll nicht
sinnvoll
ja also das teilen von gruppen ist immer
ganz hat einen größeren effekt als man
vielleicht sozusagen intuitiv erwarten
würde also wenn ich zum beispiel eine
klasse von 20 schülern habe und
schülerinnen die wohl jeder mit jedem im
prinzip kontakt hat und die pro eine
person die da zufällig infiziertes
praktisch alle anstecken könnte wenn ich
das reduziere auf die hälfte also zehn
dann habe ich die anzahl der möglichen
transmission oder kontakte um
um 75 prozent reduziert also um ein
viertel oder um drei viertel
und das ist ein effekt der sehr viel
stärker wirkt also das verkleinern von
gruppen hat einen stärkeren effekt hat
man vielleicht erwarten würde nochmal
ganz allgemein gefragt junge menschen
das war eine ganze zeit lang vor allem
im sommer die gruppe in der sich
unheimlich viel infektionsgeschehen
gezeigt hat ist das eine
bevölkerungsgruppe die man per se als
infektionsträger bezeichnen kann also
eben auch schülerinnen und schüler ja
also das ist ein diffuses geschehen
momentan und man kann nicht sozusagen
eine sparte rauspicken und sagen dass
bis jetzt die treibende betreibende
population segment genauso wenig wie man
das tatsächlich evidenzbasiert
herauspicken könnte
in welchen unter welchen umständen das
passiert bis auf einige wenige wo man
das weiß zum beispiel clubs wo halt
viele menschen den innenräumen zusammen
eng zusammen sind das das ist klar
evident aber das lässt sich sehr stark
oder nur sehr schwierig differenzieren
und infizieren
man muss sagen ganz allgemein sind
kontakte wenig hilfreich man muss darauf
achten insgesamt als gesellschaft die
kontakte im moment möglichst gering zu
halten dazu noch mal eine frage zum
thema schule von michael schulz über
youtube wird es länger winterferien
geben längere beziehungsweise vielleicht
anders ungefragt sie können das
vielleicht nicht beantworten aber würde
es sinn machen dass man längere
winterferien hat
wie sehen sie das also wie gesagt alles
was kontakte reduziert ist sozusagen aus
der sicht der modelle sinnvoll
wir haben auch viel schon ich habe viel
mit kollegen diskutiert also die reine
modellieren inwiefern sowas effizient
wäre und wenn man sich die modelle
anschaut dann ist das natürlich sehr
effizient aber es ist halt eine
politische entscheidung wie hoch dieser
preis ist auch wer wäre ich habe selbst
kleine kinder
ich weiß was das bedeutet auch und da
muss man das halt dann gesellschaftlich
entscheiden also politisch entscheiden
ob dieses hoch genug ist
es gibt natürlich auch immer um die
tests sage ich gerade auch mal die frage
auf von monika schäfer über facebook
tests meint sie sind auch so
so für die katz ich werde heute negativ
getestet gehe beim arzt raus und stecken
nicht an nur eine momentaufnahme was
bringt also ein test
ja also das ist sozusagen so eine art
anekdotische szenario also natürlich
kann das passieren
die frage ist nur ob das im aggregat in
der summe bei vielen menschen passiert
und da ist es natürlich sinnvoll sich
testen zu lassen weil es einfach die
wahrscheinlich also erstmal weist man
dann ob man ansteckend ist das ist ja
eigentlich worum es geht wenn man
herauskriegen ob man andere anstecken
kann und nicht ob man angesteckt ist da
ist es immer dieser diese diese denkt er
die man machen muss das geht ja nicht
nur um einen selbst und ob man dann sich
angesteckt haben sondern dass man andere
menschen anstecken kann
und das kriegt man ja raus wenn man
positive man negativ getestet ist dann
weiß man mit einer ist man dann keine
andere personen anstecken kann die
nächste zeit man kann es nicht natürlich
selbst anstecken noch eine frage zu den
tests da die momentan knapper werden
also die kapazitäten doch irgendwie an
grenzen stoßen sind die zahlen trotzdem
noch verlässlich und aussagekräftig ja
weil man ja gleichzeitig zu den
fallzahlen und den hospitalisierungen
und und der todesrate oder der
sterberate und den positiv sehr positiv
rate der test auch anschaut wie viel
getestet wird also diese kurve ist auch
in diesen strauß den die eingangs
erwähnt habe mit drin und das wird
berücksichtigt schauen wir doch auf das
thema impfstoff da gibt es heute
erfreulich ist dass mainz unternehmen
bayern tag und der amerikanische
pharmariese pfizer wollen noch heute in
den usa die sogenannte no zulassung
beantragen für ihren impfstoff und damit
kann er sehr wahrscheinlich noch in
diesem jahr auf den markt kommen wir
schauen uns das auch noch mal an
der impfstoff von biontech und pfizer
eine riesen hoffnung für die welt denn
er soll zu 95 prozent wirksam sein
in den usa wird er nun auf den weg
gebracht die beantragung einer notfall
zulassung in den usa ist ein
entscheidender schritt um unseren
impfstoffkandidaten so schnell wie
möglich der weltbevölkerung zur
verfügung zu stellen
der impfstoff ist an 43.000 menschen
getestet worden nach angaben von beyond
eck und pfizer wurden dabei keine
schwerwiegenden nebenwirkungen
festgestellt deshalb rechnen sie mit
einer schnellen zulassung
sobald wir grünes licht haben ist es
unser ziel innerhalb weniger stunden mit
der auslieferung zu beginnen
für die eu wird der antrag auf zulassung
in kürze erwartet das verfahren läuft
dann so der hersteller beantragt die
zulassung bei der emea der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur ema prüft ob der
impfstoff hochwertig wirksam und sicher
ist falls ja empfiehlt sie die zulassung
die entscheidung liegt bei der
eu-kommission biontech und weise haben
vorab schon studiendaten eingereicht
damit am ende schneller entschieden
werden kann ohne abstriche bei der
sicherheit beschleunigt klingt für viele
beteiligten ja so dass es die studien
verkürzt werden aber dem ist nicht so
das einzige was hier beschleunigt wird
das ist der administrative prozess der
zulassung da langfristige daten über
sicherheit und wirksamkeit noch fehlen
wird eine zulassung mit auflagen
erwartet wir möchten natürlich auch eine
langzeit verfolgung haben das heißt
unerwartete effekte die wir jetzt nicht
im blick haben die vielleicht auch bei
den tierversuchen ich aufgetreten sind
möchten wir messen möchten wir gemeldet
bekommen
wenn alles gut läuft könnte der
impfstoff in europa noch im dezember auf
den markt kommen
also vielleicht noch immerhin im
dezember kann denn der impfstoff aus
ihrer sicht also als teil einer
gesamtstrategie nochmal da also
natürlich einen beitrag leisten dass mit
sicherheit aber wie lange würde es auch
dauern bis der sich dann signifikant
bemerkbar macht ihre einschätzung nach
also erstmal ist es natürlich für die
gesamt dynamik
so ein bisschen licht am ende des
tunnels weil wir natürlich über den
impfstoff der dann verteilt wird immer
mehr leute immunisieren die da deren
kontakte dann für die dynamik für das
virus keine rolle mehr spielen weil sie
nicht mehr genutzt werden können und je
nachdem wie das logistisch abläuft ist
es dann halt eine frage dann nur noch
der zeit wie die diese leute nimmt man
dann in den modellen aus der population
und das hat dann natürlich dann direkten
einfluss auf die auf die dynamik der
pandemie und je mehr leute hat so
ausgenommen werden
als kandidaten für das virus desto
schneller geht es dann runter also das
ist dann sozusagen auch wieder das thema
herdenimmunität also wenn ein bestimmter
wert erreicht das von leuten die sich
nicht mehr anstecken können das wird
immer angegeben mit 55 prozent 60 70
prozent so was um den dreh dann ist eben
diese herdenimmunität erreicht robert
schäfer schreibt auf youtube selbst mit
impfstoff könnte es noch zu weiteren
wellen kommen bis eben diese besagte
herdenimmunität erreicht es halten sie
das für möglich oder sogar für
wahrscheinlich dass es eben weitere
wellen geben wird bis dahin also für
möglich halte ich das natürlich weil
wenn wir jetzt aus dieser zweiten bälle
raus kommen und dann wieder auf ein
niveau kommen wo die kontakt
rückverfolgung von den gesundheitsämtern
effektiv gehandhabt werden kann dann
kann man sich vorstellen dass bei
niedrigen fallzahlen wir dort auch
bleiben
aber wir haben ja auch im sommer gesehen
und auch nicht nur in deutschland
sondern in ganz vielen ländern europas
dass das auch wieder losging den usa
sind wir drei wellen im prinzip und eine
hohe dynamik auch in anderen ländern
sowie halt wir uns wieder normal
verhalten sieht das virus ja wieder
genau die gleiche situation und dann
breitete sich wieder aus und es ist
durchaus möglich dass man noch ne welle
miterlebt ist möglich aber nicht nötig
denn wir haben auch andere länder schon
gesehen die das nicht erlebt haben und
ja das ist also auf jeden fall im
bereich des möglichen
ich denke generell die
befürchtungen besteht natürlich schon
bei vielen die uns jetzt auch zu schauen
dass man im prinzip sich bewegt in
wellen tälern das ist also jetzt wieder
zu verschaffen maßnahmen gekommen ist
dass es vielleicht im dezember wieder
etwas lockerer zugehen kann weil die
zahlen etwas runter gehen wobei die
momentan immer noch relativ hoch sind
als wir haben schon darüber gesprochen
im dezember werden die lockerungen
wahrscheinlich noch nicht allzu kräftig
auswahl aber das ist halt immer wieder
zu neuen shutter und dann kommen könnte
ist das in ihren augen die beste
strategie oder gebe es alternativen dazu
wie man mit diesem thema umgehen könnte
also ich sehe das so also das ist eine
sache die wir verstehen müssen
es wird ja davon gesprochen dass das
eine naturkatastrophe ist diese pandemie
und das ist es auch
aber es ist keine naturkatastrophe wie
ein hurricane oder ein tsunami gegen die
man nichts ausrichten kann also wie
kommen ein und man kann sie nicht
aufhalten
das ist bei einer pandemie anders im
prinzip liegt es ja in unserer hand weil
wir das ich sage immer das virus frist
unsere kontakte oder ernährt sie von
unseren kontakten und über die können
wir ja entscheiden
und deshalb haben wir das in der hand
entweder durch politische maßnahmen oder
durch eigene entscheidung
das ist ein großer unterschied und gibt
uns eine große macht diese dynamik zu
beeinflussen
und das macht es aber auch kompliziert
weil eine zweite welle jetzt zum
beispiel ist für uns jetzt keine
neuigkeit mehr in der ersten welle da
war das neu die angst war vielleicht
groß jetzt kommt die zweite welle
die leute hatten coroner müdigkeit jetzt
erkennen sie wieder dass sie sich wieder
anders verhalten müssen es gibt neue
maßnahmen dann geht es vielleicht wieder
runter bei einer dritten welle werden
vielleicht die menschen denken bloß
nicht noch mal wir sind sehr sehr
vorsichtig so dass wir die fallzahlen
auf einem sehr niedrigen niveau halten
werden also das ist halt eine starke
rückkopplung zwischen dem was wir lernen
unserem verhalten und der krankheits
dynamik das ist halt eng mit unserem
verhalten verbunden und deshalb kann man
sehr schwer sagen was in zukunft
passiert vielleicht auch mal eine
abschließende frage an sich man sie sind
auch kein prophet aber so mit
welchen gedanken schauen sie auf dass
herr 2021 wird das dann die wende
bringen und auf was müssen wir uns bis
dahin noch einstellen
also ich bin ich schaue jetzt erst mal
was jetzt in den nächsten wochen
passiert das ist wichtig dass die
fallzahlen untergehend gegebenenfalls
auch dass man sich noch mal zusammen
nimmt politisch aber auch jedes
individuum dass die kontakte reduziert
werden das war über weihnachten drüber
hinwegkommen das und dass wir im
frühjahr halte niedrigen fallzahlen
sehen werden dass der impfstoff
ausgerollt wird um dann zu sehen
natürlich tag da die die effekte sein
werden und dann muss man halt echt jetzt
noch mal dann durchhalten aber es ist ja
auch ein gutes signal dass das für den
impfstoff haben werden der wirksam ist
noch hohe effizienz hat so dass man auch
einfach dann schon so ein bisschen weiß
jetzt machen wir das noch jedes jahr
vielleicht noch um 34 ja oder ja sogar
mit aber dann
dann haben wir das dann am 7 und das
heißt weihnachten 2020 fällt eher
bescheiden und im kleinen kreis aus ja
vielleicht ist das ja auch eine gute
sache ja das kommt ganz darauf an aber
da mögen sie durchaus recht haben ich
glaube jedenfalls wir werden noch das
eine oder andere mal auch über dieses
thema sprechen gerne mit ihnen auch
wieder professor dirk brockmann war das
von der humboldt-universität zu berlin
vielen dank für dieses gespräch und euch
natürlich auch vielen dank fürs
zuschauern einen hinweis habe ich noch
es gab eine große diskussion bei uns
über böllerverbot an silvester in den
sozialen netzwerken darüber machen wir
dann vielleicht mal an anderer stelle
einen eigenen stream darum ging es heute
ja erkennbar nicht trotzdem vielen dank
für die rege beteiligung ich hoffe es
hat euch trotzdem ein bisschen spaß
gemacht und auch was gebracht an
erkenntnisgewinn
vielen dank fürs mitmachen euch einen
schönen abend und ein schönes wochenende
bis demnächst